you recently went back to your high
school reunion I did I never got to do
that I didn't even know mine happened so
like so yeah what was that like
um were they freaking out it was it was
half and half I got to be honest so this
was the high school that I left after my
sophomore year to move to Nashville to
do this so I didn't graduate from here
so I was kind of like an honorary Bobcat
but um my my best friend
um graduated from there and I went with
her and um it was so interesting because
we walked in the room and it was people
were having dinner and it was the same
people at the table was like look yeah
that was after that was after we drank
yeah see
that's what it looked like in the studio
when I was recording you're drunk yeah
yeah um it was really it was really
beautiful
um because it was actually the 11 year
reunion and it was just really cool to
see everyone and everyone's in a
different phase of life but yeah you
know we're all just growing up and it's
like a really cool it was really I don't
know heartfelt oh I love that yeah I did
I didn't even know mine existed whenever
they were I'm like old enough so like
there's probably been many
um but wait were you what were you like
in high school we know you weren't as
popular as Frank but Frank
how was it I went to a boarding school
so I traveled but I I wanted to go it
wasn't one of those a lot of people
think when I tell them that I was sent
there by my parents but I actually yeah
enjoyed it and wanted to go and it was
kind of like mini college but who's the
guy who was the guy who you saw your
your reunion who said now I'm this
person
there wasn't a guy
that's also a little bit of childhood
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]